one thing that I've been doing in my
tour repeatedly when I talk about the
first chapter of my book which is stand
up straight with your shoulders back
it's a discussion of hierarchies and and
their eternal nature right because my
claim is and is not my claim I think
it's mere fact that organisms that have
to cooperate and compete with other
organisms of their type inevitably
arrange themselves into hierarchies and
that's been going on for so long which
is at least 300 million years that our
nervous systems have adapted to
hierarchies as if they're a permanent
element of being right more permanent
than trees like seriously permanent at
the most fundamental neurochemical the
one that regulates the entire brain
serotonin is acutely sensitive to
hierarchical distinctions and so that's
part of the proposition I laid that
proposition forward was to say whatever
pitfalls hierarchies might produce you
cannot lay them at the feet of the
West's patriarchy or capitalism it's
like that's a non-starter you're wrong
and not just a little bit wrong you're
so seriously wrong that if you insist
upon doing that you won't even achieve
your own aims because you're actually
not grappling with the problem the
problem is if hierarchies are a problem
which they are the problem is way more
serious than mere capitalism it's way
deeper and if you're actually interested
in rectifying the constantly the
negative consequences of hierarchies
then you're gonna have to get a lot more
sophisticated than they're then you're
idiot Marxism so so so part of the
elaboration of that argument is well
hierarchies are inevitable because we
have to solve complex problems and we
have to solve them socially and when you
implement a solution to a complex
problem socially you produce a hierarchy
because some people are better at the
implementation than others so there's a
hierarchy of competence and then there's
a hierarchy of distribution of the
Spoils and so and in both of those
hierarchies you get a disproportionate
clumping of resource
at the top and dispossession at the
bottom it's in the nature of hierarchies
so what's the left for the left is to
remind those who are benefiting from the
hierarchies that the hierarchy comes at
a cost and the cost is the clumping of
people at the bottom and that that's an
eternal cost and it's not trivial and so
that's what the left should be properly
focused on the Left should be providing
the voice of those who are dispossessed
by hierarchies and the right should be
saying yeah but the damn hierarchies are
necessary and they're not only necessary
but they're also productive then the
left says yes but they tilt towards
tyranny and they can be occupied
inappropriately by people who are
playing games of power fair enough the
right has to take that into account the
hierarchy can reach it reach it if I and
is likely to do that and it can be taken
over by people who are corrupt and
that's likely to happen and so but but
it's okay because the dialogue can work
out the the right can say well yeah we
need the damn hierarchies and they need
to be buttressed and the left can say
yes but they have to be maintained
properly so they don't deteriorate and
degenerate and and I think that's I
think that's ancient wisdom I think the
ancient Egyptians had figured that out
in their symbolic representations so now
when the left goes too far
it does something like say well how
about no hierarchies it's like no how
about not wrong because all that happens
if you flatten one of the things that
happens if you flatten out the hierarchy
is that you can't even organize your
perceptions you can't perceive the world
without looking at the world through a
hierarchy of value and if because you
can't perceive the world unless you make
one thing more important than all the
other things because you don't even know
what to look at and if one thing isn't
more important than all the other things
then you have nothing to aim at if you
have nothing to aim at then you have no
meaning in your life so the left can't
just demolish the hierarchies in the
name of some equality of outcome let's
say because you blow out the future you
leave people aimless and you destroy
the very institutions that allow people
to make competent progress in the world
that's not an acceptable outcome so we
have to we have to agree to live with
the tension necessity for hierarchies
the proclivity for them to pathologize
and the the necessary voice of the left
in speaking for thee for the
dispossessed